The solution we just saw has some problems, it had wires the ID generation into
the person class, so if somebody is writing code and they want to use the
person's class in their code, but they want ID's to be generated differently.
Maybe they want ID's to start at a 1000 or may be they only want prime ID's
they can't change the way the ID's are being assigned so what would be a better
way to assign ID's to our persons? We would create a new interface, IdProvider
which would have a method next to Id. You can think of an interface sort of
like a class for now. We'll talk about these more in lesson nine. But now that
we have this when we create a person, we can take in an ID provider, and use it
to set the ID. Then we don't need the static variable anymore. This is what
objects are all about, if you want different policies, you create different
objects. There's no reason to be tied to a static variable in order to count
the ID's. In production code you should never use static variables unless you
declare them final and capitalize them and use them as constants, static
variable seem convenient, but when you write real code they cause bugs because
they don't get cleaned up when you are done the way objects do